from the Salt Lake Tribune these Utah
Brothers want the Supreme Court to
remove Joe Biden from the White House
and reinstate Donald Trump the U.S
Supreme Court could decide on Friday
whether or not to hear a long shot
lawsuit that alleges members of Congress
broke their oath of office by certifying
the 2020 presidential election now
I'm sorry if this comes off as
dismissive
but long shot is an understatement not
because I'm not making an argument on
the merits I always think that merits
should be heard out and sometimes that
means summary dismissal sometimes it
means Discovery sometimes it means
summary judgment whatever
um but the idea that what are we looking
at 300 the idea that 387 members of
Congress
the President and Vice President would
be removed by the Supreme Court is just
so far-fetched
I do not believe there is a reality in
which that could happen Okay obviously
if there's infinite realities it happens
infinite number of times but I'm just
like
as much as it I mean I I wish
how amazing would it be if I come Monday
and Supreme Court's like we're gonna
hear the lawsuit and then they bang the
gamble like you're right Congress
dismissed president gone and then we
have no Congress and we have no
executive branch that's pretty good one
can only dream right right right I think
anything's possible I don't know anymore
the last five years have proven to me
that literally anything's possible but
this does seem like an evolution a lot
of the Q stuff where people I had
friends I would go over their house and
be like all these people have died and I
think they're you know in Guantanamo and
I'm like I don't know about that dude
but maybe well I don't trust these news
outlets like the Salt Lake Tribune says
it's making Acquisitions of Fraud and
all that stuff maybe I just don't
believe them because I think there is
actual grounds for a lawsuit based on
procedural elements of the 2020 election
that is to say is universal mail-in
voting constitutional some of these
questions never got resolved in many
states Texas V Pennsylvania never even
got hurt I think it was Texas beef
Pennsylvania was the major lawsuit and
the Supreme Court refused to hear it so
there never even was an argument about
whether or not anything that was going
on was constitutional
I think the court should hear that if
that is the basis for this I certainly
don't see a reality in which for 300
nearly the entirety of Congress is
removed I think I think 75 of this
country would be in favor of that isn't
that kind of crazy approval for Congress
is so low that if they probably if they
held like a like a like a Convention of
states and a referendum on like just
removing and restarting Congress I bet
it would pass probably so I'm seeing a
lot of people cheer the last few days
which is exciting in terms of Kevin
mccarth the speaker right yeah you know
I see people I'm friends with who
disagree with me on certain things
politically but we can all enjoy that
because it's just uh stalling a place
that I think seeks to uh harm us anyway
well at 10 o'clock they are going to
reconvene in the house and then Kevin
McCarthy's claiming he's going to win so
we'll see but I I can say this whatever
ends up happening with the Brunson thing
I'm gonna go ahead and bet probably
nothing I think the Supreme Court will
not hear it if they do I will be very
surprised
but regardless of what you think about
this case
I think it's fair to say that there is
something deeply wrong with this country
and that and that and that we all
recognize it whether the left recognizes
it or the right does the establishment
there is something deeply wrong and what
that solution is
you'd think would be outrageous of
grievances through a lawsuit but it
seems like none of these things ever
have an impact and the argument from the
machine is always they're meritless and
it's just like come on man you know as
you wrote about with the Kerry Lake
stuff they they the judge ruled against
Kerry Lake she's appealing but there
there was evidence presented that needs
to be accounted for that is to say that
why were the tabulators rejecting
ballots because they were 19-inch images
on 20-inch paper so they couldn't go
through that creates a problem and you
can't just be like oh don't worry they
dropped it in a Ballot Box and got
counted later and it's like okay so
let's have a conversation about how at
was it 72 locations yeah someone changed
the images on these printers yep like
that there's if they've just started
talking about on the on the second day
of trial exactly and they denied it
happen in the first day right so if the
end result is that there was one guy who
went around pressing the buttons lock
him up but they just ignore it that's
the problem even the courtroom couldn't
run things technically what like
proficient it's like if a small closed
system like a courtroom couldn't even
get like HDMI cables right what makes
you think all these elections wait wait
you guys still have faith in government
you think they're going to do something
good for you it's like I'm trying to I
know I don't have faith in the
government but it's like I'm trying to
keep faith in people but I'm having I'm
losing faith in people because I even
think if we remove the government like I
was saying to you about moving on to and
yeah I know but but how because I'm
surrounded by people who truly worship
The Establishment well the argument I
would make is because
Psychopaths usually flee to uh the
biggest positions of power this is why
government is a vector for them and we
should always push push back against
them sorry I thought you were raising
your hand trying to say um I got a Tech
Deck
yeah practicing with I usually talk with
my left so I'm using my right I agree
but but yeah the other thing about that
trial that was upsetting is like I was
also kind of having flashbacks to the
the summer of the riots because even if
you have evidence even if they show it
in court a whole country could look at
it together and half of them could just
not believe the evidence like even if
it's a video showing these things not
working people be like nah don't believe
it and it's like the problem isn't about
the evidence it's not about the the
system really because now it's really
about just how we view our ourselves and
the world and I that's where I'm like my
pessimist nihilism is starting to creep
in because we're not in a good place
there totally same I'm so white pilled
about the future I so much because I was
going to ask you like you you talk to a
lot of survivors yeah how do you keep
hope and when you hear all these like
dark stories
so there's evil and there's darkness in
the world
but there's also a lot of good in the
world and good and light and love will
win in the end and unfortunately not
everybody will make it there with us
not everybody gonna make it but it will
win in the end history has shown us this
repeatedly over and over again no matter
how dark Things Are
some will make it and good and light
love will win the end and it doesn't
stay bad forever I love that I want to I
want to ask one quick question before we
go to super chats I was just thinking
about this because I'm seeing people
chat my question is and it's not just
for you but for anyone can a woman
choose to be a sex worker at the request
of a man
can you say that again if a man asks a
woman to be a sex worker working for him
and she says yes
is is that a legitimate Choice she made
so the woman is over 18 and the man's
over 18 and are you is there an abortion
is there coercion like when you say ask
just just uh just we'll put plain and
simple a man goes to him and says I'm
going to create a cam business how would
you like to be one of my cam girls and
she says yes is that a legitimate choice
on her part
it just depends on it it depends on the
the entire breakdown of it so uh and by
the way every there everyone's gonna
have an opinion on this and many people
won't agree with me
um I believe that an individual can be a
willing adult Entertainer
um but that would have to come from
inside the individual that wants to be a
willing adult Entertainer
um as far as someone asking like if you
said to me hey Eliza I um need an extra
host on the show will you come be a host
on the show I could then choose but I if
even if I didn't ask you to be a host on
the show then I would still be choosing
to be a host on the show does that mean
I don't know so so each situation is
going to be different so if coercion if
Force product coercions involved it's
human trafficking if it's not involved
then it's not even if it's just having
you host a show
no no no no no no I'm sorry I wasn't
trying to mix it too with the caming no
well so this is that would only be labor
trafficking if you used for spotted
coercion to get me to work for you for
free and you kept the money
so for free so if you were free or a
little bit of a pay so this is what I
was getting to because someone someone
said in the chat regret is not rape or
something like that and others made the
point that if women chose to do a job
for someone the reasons they chose to do
the job aren't aren't material and so
here's what I was thinking I made a
tweet that got a lot of attention and I
thought it was hilarious I said if sex
work is work then can an employer
require his his staff to service him I
remember that tweet Tim and but it's but
it's but here's the problem I remember
that too it's a real question it's a
real question that they can't answer and
that's why they got mad because clearly
sex work is not work sex work is so no
means no and if an individual at any
time uh expresses that they're not
comfortable they should be allowed to go
or allowed to stop without uh I'm going
back to the original question just to be
clear
um but as far as coercion goes it would
depend and some folks identify so do I
think someone willingly do that work yes
so I think folks can be coerced into
doing the work yes so and that would be
up into the that would be up to the
individual doing it and in the case of a
Survivor stepping forward or victims
stepping forward we would let the Court
decide if it was coerced so was that
person able to leave at any time right
so anytime yes so would it be coercion
if I said Shane
move to from move from from California
to West Virginia where you will have
this job hosting this show
and don't worry we'll make sure you have
a place to live and if Shane was like
man it's gonna be really hard for me to
move don't worry man we'll take care of
you then he gets here and I say I want
you to take the garbage out now
otherwise I'm I'm firing you is that
coercion
it would depend on the nature I mean
there's a lot of variables there I don't
know was that part of his job that you
agreed on right yeah this is my point if
if if you go to a person who lives in
Canada and say move to the United States
yes you'll be here on a work visa we'll
pay you x amount of dollars we'll give
you a place to live and you will do job
a yes then they arrive and you say you
know what we also want you to take the
garbage out from now on and they say hey
man I didn't agree to do the garbage
well if you don't do it I'm I'm firing
you you can't but if you fire me how am
I going to get back to my home country
well that's too bad you should have
thought of that like is that coercion
are they holding the papers are they
restricting them from walking out the
door no you can leave good luck getting
a plane back to Canada though and
finding a place to live once you go back
to your country is that coercion
maybe you lured them there under false
pretenses but I would let the courts
decide coercion I don't to me that
doesn't sound coercive it is coerced it
is coercion in a way but not in the way
of human trafficking what if a guy said
to a woman come work for me and be the
host of a show yeah we'll pay you then
she gets here and they say as part of
your job you'll be performing sex acts
and she goes no well then you can get
out you're fired and is that coercion
yes so so right this is my point the
only difference is the action if the
action is something like physical labor
you say well maybe it's for the
coordinate side if it's sexual hands
down it is that's my point sex work is
not work sex work is clearly distinct
sex works is clearly its own category
well that would also possibly fall under
sexual harassment that would be a couple
different uh crimes but I'm not gonna
you this is the point I was making the
left when they come out and say sex work
is work they are basically saying that
whether you are performing a sex act or
taking out the garbage you're doing
you're doing work
and then that's why I ask that question
no that's not true because sex is
clearly in a specific protected category
I mean like access of sexual nature that
taking out the garbage is not you go to
a lawyer and you say I want you to take
it out your garbage if they say no you
can fire them you cannot go to a lawyer
and say I want you to start performing
gratification on another person that's
illegal
so so as much as many of these leftists
try to make that argument it's just not
the case and that's why I agree with you
telling someone to come out for a job
that's like juggling bowling pins then
when they get there you say you also got
to clean the floors and they say no well
then you're fired yeah well too bad you
got fired but if if they say come out
here to juggle bowling pins once they
get there they say now you've got to
perform a sex acts okay now you're into
that trafficking like you're in that
coercion territory it happens a lot more
than you'd think actually
the switch up happens pretty quickly too
but it's a blink of an eye and
especially when you're scared it's hard
to just uh walk away it's interesting
that it's a more it's a like that view
is more conservative the the leftist
progressive view tends to be that sex
work is just work and who cares so
unless and until you advocate for that
to be applied to the labor market and
then all of a sudden the 50 year old fat
slob has the right to incorporate in his
smoothie making position sexual
gratification well it's just work
that was that was kind of my point like
if you think it is just work and I don't
then why couldn't an employer say job
description for store clerk ringing up
the cheeseburgers handing out the bags
and giving [ __ ] thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time